the Burj Al Arab is a feat of
architectural design as it is built on
an artificial island just above the
ocean creating a one-of-a-kind floating
look but how is the Burj Al Arab able to
avoid flooding due to natural variation
ocean levels moreover what will be the
fate of the Burj Al Arab over the next
few decades as ocean levels continue to
rise well to answer this we have to
first take a look at how the Burj Al
Arab was built it all started in 1993
when resort company jumera International
wanted to build a national landmark that
would become iconic of Dubai and a price
was not a factor as a result they asked
architect Tom Wright to come up with
such an iconic building eventually after
months of planning and sketching with
architecture firm Dudley as Atkins and
partners they came up with a building
that resembled a Dow of an Arabian
fishing boat reminiscent of their past
from the start
Dubai wanted the building to be built
off the coast so that it would not be
buried by surrounding development as a
result once plans were finalized they
started out by reclaiming land from the
ocean which is an extremely difficult
process construction workers start off
by drilling 230 concrete piles measuring
130 feet into the seabed which would
support the weight of the new building
this is why the Burj Al Arab is
resistant to shifting sand underneath it
it's because it's anchored to the sea
floor moving on constructors surrounded
the island with precast concrete these
were specifically designed hollow blocks
that reduce a force of waves on Island
preventing rough waves from shaking a
building after the skeleton of steel
piles and precast concrete was complete
the inside of the skeleton was filled
with sand extracted from an offshore
seabed this first step of creating the
island itself took over two years to
complete but this was just the beginning
Architects still had to ensure that the
building wouldn't be knocked down or
shifted from strong Gulf winds Seesmic
tremors and a corrosive atmosphere to
battle these forces the Burj Al Arab was
built using a strong steel exoskeleton
but these only answered general
national questions about the building so
how is the building able to prevent
flooding
well the secret to this is a structure
they built between the top of the island
and the start of the usable space
perforated concrete blocks from mounted
on a bedrock and a honeycomb pattern
this large structure acts as a ginormous
artificial sponge kind of like a drain
on the side of a pool however evidently
this can only be so effective what will
happen as sea levels continue to rise
well actually though the media portrays
rising sea levels as a dangerous threat
to coastal cities and Islands
it really isn't now don't get me wrong
here global warming and melting polar
caps are definitely an issue that should
be addressed but saying that this issue
will cause shorelines to recede and
Islands distinct is just simply wrong
studies show that between nineteen
hundred nineteen ninety sea levels rose
between 1.2 and 1.7 millimeters per year
however by the year 2000 they're rising
at three point two millimeters per year
and in 2016 they were rising at three
point four millimeters per year while
this is a concerning increase this is
nowhere near enough to sink the Burj Al
Arab the specifics on how many feet to
the Burj Al Arab sits above sea level
are not publicly available but we can't
make an educated estimate based on the
palm islands which are situated right
next to it during low tide the lowest
portion of the island is situated just
13 feet above the sea though this seems
like a dangerously low number this is
simply an irrational fear the maxed out
range at jumera beach is 2.1 meters or
6.9 feet so even during the highest of
tides the palm islands would be six feet
above sea level assuming that the Burj
Al Arab is constructed with similar
precautions they would be well over five
feet above sea level even during the
highest of tides so at a rate of three
point four millimeters per year it would
take four hundred and forty eight years
for sea levels to become a threat to
Roberta Arab even at a rate of ten
millimeters per year it would take over
150 years for sea level rise
level of the Burj Al Arab and this is
not even considering the flood
prevention mechanism and you have to
keep in mind that this is the worst case
scenario it's unlikely at the height
above sea level is only 5 feet for the
Burj Al Arab it's probably closer to 10
feet also is very unlikely for the sea
level rising rate to spike up to 10
millimeters per year consequently a more
realistic estimate would leave more than
500 years of time before Dubai would
even have to consider rising sea levels
as an issue and after that time I'm not
even sure that this building would even
exist and if it did I'm not sure it
would be so heavily commemorated in a
fast paced city such as Dubai but they
are constantly beating out their old
architectural feats and hey if rising
sea levels did ever become an issue
Dubai has already messed with creating
artificial rain and trucking out poop
so maybe villas conceived another crazy
plan to decrease sea levels if you guys
thought this video explained the risk of
the Burj Al Arab flooding well that
makes you drop a leg and consider
subscribing you flexi more questions
just like this one logically answered
but until then I'm Ari and I'll see you
guys on the next one